[Music]
fantastic thank you thank you I like
this pompadour thing is that I've been
doing this about 20 years occasionally
and every time I see you I do compliment
you aren't you're very nice about that
we've bumped into each other a few times
and and you're always very kind to me
and it does me not to because style is
your thing like this is you're an expert
on style this is your a style maven yeah
you are you always look very nice very
beautiful and I was just curious
okay do you ever look back say back on
your childhood and see things that you
did back then that now caused you pain
now that style is actually part of your
it's a big part of your profession
anything you did as a kid that just do
you hate you know when I was 12 I really
wanted to pluck my eyebrows that's what
every girl wants to do right when you
become a teenager and my mom didn't let
me and so I went in the shower I mind
you I was 12 I wasn't smart enough to
bring a mirror in there and I shaved
what I thought was the center and I came
out and I only had just the ends just
just a little bit right here just a
little taste of an eyebrow just right
here and my mom was so mad she's like
Nicole what did you do and you know I'm
a teenager I was the worst liar and I
was like mom I was in the shower and
they just fell off someone I mean a lot
of us and young people today do it they
see people on TV and they say I want to
dress like that person you know in the
80s there were guys that saw dawn Jansen
Don Johnson on Miami Vice and said I
want to be that guy was there someone
that you're watching on TV there was I
was a big punky brewster fan and I don't
know if you all remember but she did the
mismatched everything so I would go with
you know a green sock and a red sock and
then a black shoe and a white shoe and I
thought I was killing it you guys like I
was like oh I am Joe everything and
other people just thought that you would
hit your head or say
yeah I don't remember I didn't watch
Andy I know you watched a lot of punky I
didn't still do do you know you do
something that that you're managed to
pull off you like to wear headgear I do
yes you like to to put things and I
think that in fashion and I don't know
much about fashion clearly but I think
that would be the boldest thing that you
could do is to wear something on your
head or headgear of some kind because
that's making a real statement
well fashion is from head to toe so I
mean if you're gonna put fancy shoes on
then you've got to decorate your head as
well right
I guess you're talking to a complete
idiot about these things but we have a
picture here I think this is from your
show where the where the stylist is
putting is that something that you would
really wear in public that looks like
something a Norse God would wear like
you know Oscar it was was a designer on
on Fashion Star and that was the first
piece that I saw of his and that's what
made me so drawn to him because he did
the most elaborate headpiece and I loved
it I mean I would wear that anywhere I
would get coffee in it well I'm curious
I'm a tall fellow as you know and people
can't tell watching the show but in
reality I'm about I'm about nine feet
tall yeah and I have an odor note you
can't tell but no I'm very tall and I
have a big head would I be someone who
you would would you recommend that I
wear hats or anything like that or
should I should I do emphasize my head
should I be emphasizing my head you know
I actually funny that you mention it I
brought a gift for you from my
collection I brought something to you
can do do you mind if I put it on you
okay that's cool okay all right I think
I honestly don't know where you're going
I didn't we can talk about this
beforehand just close your eyes and
trust me okay this is from your
collection yeah this is something yes
okay you've got a center I feel my hair
being crushed
no look like that but we're gonna bring
out but yes there you go
[Applause]
I really do I really well it's like I
feel like a chandelier fell on me okay I
got really drunk on a riverboat and a
chandelier fell on me is this something
is this something you would wear I think
you look very chic I have one that I
wear that piece all the time I like how
you pulled my hair through it's very
nice well I know that this piece is
important to you so I wanted to you know
keep that kind of iconic let's get me
Attorney two different cameras quickly I
just want to see how well it you get a
little attitude
it's got it oh well that's the problem
is they do turn my head quickly